[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde les démons de Poutine avant
l'invasion de l'Ukraine Vladimir Poutine
fut aduler des grandes ce monde
notamment de responsables européens même
si son autoritarisme faisait l'objet de
critiques et qu'il inspirait de la
méfiance pour ces manières brutales en
vue d'éliminer tout ce qui s'opposait à
son pouvoir depuis février 2022 et le
déferlement de l'Armada militaire russe
en Ukraine détruisant sans discernement
les infrastructures vitales et décimant
des populations innocentes c'est une
toute autre appréciation de Poutine qui
est mise en exergue par les médias et la
classe politique qui louaient auparavant
l'autocrate du Kremlin on découvre ou en
fin de découvrir sa jeunesse turbulente
à Leningrad l'URSS à l'époque lorsqu'il
fréquentait la pègre de
Saint-Pétersbourg un serviteur sinon un
Ordonn peur des basses oeuvres du KGB
adresse un fossoyeur des avancées
libérales de ces prédécesseurs
Gorbatchev et yelcine dès son accession
dans les cercles du pouvoir l'adepte
d'un système de corruption à l'intérieur
de la Russie comme au sein des capitales
européennes éblouies par les fortunes
d'oligarques à la solde du Kremlin un
antioxydantalisme primaire et un menteur
invétéré comment a-t-on pu se tromper à
ce point sur le responsable d'une des
plus grandes nations de la planète dotée
de surcroît d'une puissance nucléaire
redoutable qui trompa la communauté
diplomatique internationale par ces
tirades sur l'humiliation de la Russie
mais ne manqua jamais d'exprimer en
paroles et en date je parle de Vladimir
Poutine sa puissance absolue c'est ce
que nous allons chercher à comprendre
avec mes invités madame Hélène Carrère
d'encaus vous êtes historienne
secrétaire perpétuel de l'Académie
française
l'hormoneville vous êtes journaliste
vous avez été correspondante à Moscou
pour le journal Le Figaro Alexandre
melnique vous êtes ancien diplomate
russe et professeur de géopolitique
nerijusse Alexis yunas vous êtes
ambassadeur de la République de Lituanie
en France
[Musique]
alors une question se pose Poutine un
sentiment qu'il est sorti d'un trou de
serrure caché Beast pour faire carrière
d'abord à Saint-Pétersbourg puis au
Kremlin sans qu'on sache vraiment qu'il
était dans la galette si d'abord ça
risque puis bolchevik et après à quelle
filiation politique appartient-il madame
Carrère d'Encausse
je ne dirais pas qu'il est parti à une
filiation politique il essaye de se
rattacher et d'emblée quand il est
arrivé au pouvoir il a montré qu'elle
était son Dieu c'était Pierre Legrand
c'est pas si il connaissait très bien
l'histoire de Pierre Legrand mais Pierre
Legrand incarné pour lui la puissance la
puissance du pays et je pense que si on
réfléchit à ce qu'il anime ce qu'il a
retenu de Pierre Legrand c'était l'homme
qui a édifié la puissance une puissance
ce qui a été l'Empire russe et Georges
Sokoloff mon défunt collègue qui a été
un grand professeur de d'économie de
l'URSS et de la Russie avait trouvé le
qualificatif la puissance pauvre
c'est-à-dire la puissance qui s'est
édifiée au détriment de du bien-être
social ou bien au détriment du progrès
de la modernisation et au fond on peut
dire que Poutine a retenu cette idée et
pour moi il est guidé par la volonté de
puissance aussi il est convaincu que
Pierre Legrand par sa puissance à édifié
un empire immense et il regarde de tous
les côtés et je dirais que je voudrais
dire tout de suite qu'il a réussi un
tour de force c'est à dire que Pierre
Legrand avait réussi une chose
véritablement du point de vue de la
puissance territoriale c'est un style
établir un contrôle de la Baltique pour
un pays qui n'avait pas accès au maire
il avait raté ça sur la mer Noire il
avait réussi à installer la Russie sur
la Baltique et Vladimir Poutine a réussi
à perdre le contrôle de la Baltique ce
qui est tout à fait remarqué
vous dites que lui s'apparente à Pierre
Legrand il s'apparentit se réclame il se
réclame mais il se réclame depuis quand
de Pierre Legrand parce que maintenant
on connaît son itinéraire son passé sans
rien à voir avec
j'allais dire une grandeur de tsarisme
etc non mais c'est plutôt les bas-fonds
non c'est pas son problème son problème
c'est il l'a présenté comme son modèle
cela dit les bas-fonds ça a été un voyou
de Saint-Pétersbourg c'est pas ça a été
un gamin qui a été élevé d'une façon
manifestement quand on regarde sa
biographie très libre il
fréquentait tous les voyous du quartier
et ensuite très tôt il a voulu aller
dans le caguette il est rentré dans la
véritablement dans l'instant de sécurité
et il n'était pas inconnu il était mais
il est il a été très tôt à l'étranger en
Allemagne de l'Est et par conséquent il
n'a réapparu dans son pays que
tardivement c'est votre avis monsieur
alexiunas monsieur Poutine se réclamant
de Pierre Legrand c'est comme ça qu'on
le voit dans les pays baltes et
notamment Lituanie je pense qu'il est
c'est par l'histoire c'est vrai je suis
d'accord avec Madame de secrétaire sur
ce point mais je pense que pour nous
c'est un parachutique de KGB avec les
valeurs de kg avec les valeurs de force
avec le voleur de des
de sécurité mais aussi pour nous le
régime dépotine le régime du criminel
parce que si nous avons voir tout
l'histoire de pouvoir de régime de
Poutine c'était beaucoup des crimes qui
étaient faits à l'époque comme beaucoup
de déposants étaient tués donc c'était
pas les valeurs qui a été crié par
Poutine c'était toujours cette cette
nécessité pour construire le système
criminel avec leur
station de pays avec les oligarques qui
qui sont fidèles pour pour Poutine pour
créer cette verticale et pour soutenir
le pays alors Pierre Legrand filiation
criminelle pour vous leur Mondeville au
niveau de la filiation là au niveau de
la filiation je dirais qu'il y a deux
situations pour moi Poutine en fait
c'est le digne successeur ou l'indigne
successeur de la tradition nationale
bolchevique qui est une sorte de force
d'occupation qui s'est emparée de la
Russie en 1917 et qui depuis s'accroche
au pouvoir et ne cède pas le terrain
nous avons cru en fait que que les
nationaux bolchéviques et leur version
la plus criminelle c'est-à-dire le KGB
avait cédé le terrain en 1991 et en
réalité dans les décombres des ruines du
communisme a émergé une sorte d'animal
de dragon qui est à la fois le
successeur comme je le dis donc de
Lénine de Staline de Virgin ski mais
aussi qui va puiser dans le passé
impérial parce que en réalité le
National bolchevisme avait aussi
embrassé la tradition impériale russe
donc Poutine va chercher il fait il
pratique une sorte de syncrétisme et va
chercher dans la tradition impériale
russe des éléments pour justifier en
fait la politique de revanche et de
reconquête qui l'a engagé mais je dirais
qu'il y a aussi un aspect purement
profondément criminel et là il est à la
fois check-list c'est à dire le KGB et
la pègre en fait parce que il a aussi
embrassé dans les années 90 faut bien
que voir que Poutine quand il revient de
Drèze et qu'il participe qu'il fait son
chemin dans la rue il va en réalité
devenir une sorte de de d'hommes qui
fait le lien entre les structures de
force et le monde du crime organisé et
donc c'est en fait cet homme avec toutes
ces influences différentes qui arrivent
au pouvoir et le dernier élément c'est
l'autocratie alors par exemple malnique
vous avez l'avantage si on peut dire de
connaître la Russie de l'intérieur et
même l'URSS avant vous avez même cette
même sortie de guimauve c'est-à-dire
Léna russe pour vous c'est quoi les deux
trois grands traits de la filiation
politique de Poutine cette filiation
politique du phénomène Poutine il faut
la marcher dans les profondeur de la
continuité de l'histoire de Russie qui
passe par cette parenthèse de l'Union
soviétique quand je dis les profondeurs
de l'histoire de la Russie je pourrais
parler de trois phénomènes récurrents
qui traversent toute l'histoire de la
Russie et qui s'encarnent d'une certaine
façon dans le phénomène Poutine d'abord
c'est le nihilisme juridique
c'est-à-dire la Russie la civilisation
russe les civilisations d'esclaves de
l'Est de façon générale n'avait jamais
connu de Rome c'est-à-dire à la matrice
de que droit de la légalité et donc le
nihilisme juridique c'est le rejet
viscéral de la loi et la dominance de la
morale par rapport à la loi le deuxième
phénomène c'est le phénomène qui est
assez paradoxal pour ce grand pays pour
le plus grand pays du monde en termes de
taille parce que ce pays se sent
toujours assiégés c'est un phénomène de
forteresse assiégé comme si autour de la
Russie il n'y avait que des qui voulait
la détruire donc ce phénomène on
retrouve aussi dans le caractère et les
actions de petite et troisième phénomène
c'est aussi le phénomène historique
c'est la théorie de la troisième Rome
c'est à dire la Russie ne veut pas être
comme tous les pays du monde là aussi
veut être différent la Russie veut être
la troisième Rome la première tombée la
deuxième constante Nord tombée sur le
coup de boutoir aussi de l'Empire
ottoman vous dites qu'il est le produit
de toutes ces frustrations mais
historique cette frustration historique
y compris évidemment cette parenthèse
soviétique avec cette ce terreau
nourricier des années 90 qui ont suivi
l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique on
va rentrer dans le détail alors madame
carrer d'Encausse on sait que Poutine a
commencé sa carrière à Berlin-Est comme
agent du KGB
est-ce que vous diriez qu'il est
toujours resté un cagibiste c'est-à-dire
un peu à la manière pardonnez-moi la
comparaison des Jésuites ou des
trotskistes qui
sent qu'il y ait de cause à effet bien
entendu mais ce que vous diriez que
finalement c'est le il reste toujours
l'homme du KGB même si ça a pris
d'autres dénominations FSB etc je pense
que c'est sa formation
bon c'est une fois encore je reviens
l'enfance s'est éteint manifestement un
gamin qui a été presque sans
surveillance enfin on sait que c'était
il était assez voyou il est rentré dans
le KGB il a eu à 16 ans à la révélation
qu'il avait envie de vivre dans cette
structure qui avait été inventée par
dire jinski au moment de la Révolution
et il est incontestablement c'est sa
formation mentale il n'y a pas de doute
c'est-à-dire une formation qui fait
fonder sur la je reviens sur l'idée de
puissance parce que je crois pas qu'on
puisse laisser de côté il est convaincu
que rien n'est plus fort que la
puissance le point on tient les autres
c'est celui qui est le plus fort qui
l'emporte par des méthodes qui sont
alors là
la formation cagibiste mais aussi la
formation de bolchevique est une
formation qui était sans vergogne on
évoquait tout à l'heure la criminalité
moi je dirais les gens qui passent par
la fenêtre d'une façon inattendue
inopinée etc
il y a qu'à regarder l'histoire
soviétique elle en est pleine enfin de
Trotski qu'on est allé assassiner loin
même la femme de Lénine la femme de
Lénine est morte d'une façon extrêmement
suspecte et je dirais chaque c'est une
justement le principe c'est que il y a
pas de de respect de la vie humaine il y
a le pouvoir la puissance il y a d'un
côté le pouvoir et puis le reste qui
doit suivre incontestablement c'est il
est resté je dirais le produit de cette
éducation et je voudrais tout de suite
poser une question je trouve que le
produit d'une éducation qui est tout
entière fondée sur l'idée que l'instance
qui tient je dirais tout le pays qui
tient tous les renseignements sur tout
et sur tout le monde
que ça donne un homme qui s'engage dans
une guerre pas enseigné ne savant pas de
sachant pas ni l'état du pays ni l'état
du pays où il va etc moi c'est pour moi
le plus grand mystère je ne comprends
pas que l'homme du cagué quand j'entends
dire ah mais attendez il a on l'a pas
renseigné on l'a mal renseigné mais
c'est complètement absurde enfin un
homme qui a passé sa vie dans cet
instant ce qui sait à quel point le
renseignement est fondamental qui sait à
quel point il faut se méfier des autres
qui sait à quel point on doit tenir tout
le monde qui se retrouve mal renseignée
ne sachant pas croyant que l'Ukraine
n'existe pas croyant qu'on peut envoyer
des armées qui sont pas préparées dans
un pays avec qui a été soigneusement
préparé mais c'est absolument on va
parler
que vraiment on ne peut pas dire c'est
l'homme du cagibi sans s'étonner de ce
que je dirais de son incompétence comme
homme du cahier mais est-ce que
historiquement est-ce que quelqu'un veut
répondre à cette question quand il était
au kg berlès il a accomplir adresse
pardonnez-moi à Brest erdesk est-ce que
quand il était donc en RDA à l'époque il
a commis des actions criminelles à
l'égard des pays occidentaux alors
en fait les choses commencent à sortir
en fait sur sur cette période qui a été
soigneusement si vous voulez exurger de
toutes les biographies officielles de
Poutine et ceux qui se penchaient sur
cette question était le faisait avec
beaucoup de précautions parce que
c'était un sujet extrêmement sensible
mais vous avez notamment le livre de
Catherine Belton que dont je vois que
vous avez un exemplaire juste à côté de
vous les hommes de Poutine et qui s'est
livré une enquête extrêmement
intéressante et extrêmement poussée en
fait justement du parcours de Poutine de
tout ça de son et de ses années à
dresses et ce qu'elle elle ce qu'elle
c'est que contrairement à ce que Poutine
a voulu faire croire en laissant
entendre en fait qu'il n'avait un rôle
absolument
quasiment
inexistant et totalement marginal à
Dresde il était impliqué en fait dans
d'abord la les opérations en fait de
l'interaction avec la stasie puisqu'il
avait toute une équipe de la Stasi avec
laquelle il travaillait pour recruter en
fait des espions à l'ouest et aussi
dit-elle en tout cas c'est une hypothèse
qu'elle est née mais en par exemple en
allant voir un ancien en fait de la
Fraction Armée Rouge j'ai trouvé que
c'était absolument incroyable qu'elle
est sortie ça un ancien infraction à
Montrouge donc qui était ses réseaux
terroristes Allemands qui ont commis des
attentats en Europe occidentale elle
explique en fait que Poutine d'après cet
homme qui en faisait partie faisait
partie en fait
s'occuper de superviser certaines
opérations de la Fraction Armée rouge
que je trouve quand même un pour
répondre à votre question montre qu'il
était donc en première ligne pour des
opérations extrêmement sensibles
directement dirigées contre les contre
l'Occident votre avis Alexandre à votre
question je vais convoquer mon
expérience mon passé dans un diplomate
soviétique et russe j'avais commencé ma
carrière l'ambassade de Paris dans ce
fameux bunker boulevard Lannes en 1981
vous avez résidé dans l'ambassade qui se
trouve une Grenelle qui est le président
de l'ambassadeur de Russie mais il faut
remonter un peu
à la source et la source d'abord c'est
d'où il vient Poutine comme disait
madame carré d'encaus c'était quelqu'un
qui était formé composé formaté par la
rue donc c'était quelqu'un qui
n'appartenait pas qu'on appelait la
nomenclature à soviétique et regardez
toujours cette frustration finalement
cette espèce de revanche de vengeance
par rapport à sa situation initiale
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait elle n'a pas
fait le mot Émile contrairement à moi le
mieux c'était Léna chaussée réunis il a
fait la fac de droit dans le pays du
nihilisme juridique c'est quoi la fin de
droit dans le qui me dit rien finalement
cette fac de droit mais il a compris
tout de suite que l'ascenseur social
dans ce pays à cette époque historique
c'est lequel je vais la toqué à la porte
donc du représentant Dieu que je bide
d'ailleurs il y avait toujours des
représentants dans toutes les
universités de l'Union soviétique à
l'époque je veux travailler avec on lui
a dit attends tu finis tes études et
après on verra après il était engagé il
était engagé par le que GB il voulait
être pas travailler pour le que je vais
intérieur parce que c'est plutôt la
délation etc il voulait toujours être en
espion mais ce qu'il y avait vraiment
les aptitudes pour être en vrai espion
ça c'est une question qui reste ouverte
pour moi il était nommé ou il était
nommé comme ça a été précisé par le
reste pas tout de suite il a d'abord
fait des opérations de soigner la
population
le lien que vous faites entre KGB et
industrie du crime industrie du crime ce
que je veux dire par là ce que c'était
plutôt un lieu tenant à un exécuteur des
bases des bases œuvres mais des bases
œuvres sans grande importance il
travaillait adresse ou à la représente
représentation commerciale il n'avait
même pas de passeport diplomatique drez
c'est pas la capitale de la voilà donc
c'est-à-dire son poste était
relativement subalterne il travaillait
plutôt c'était quoi ça
par exemple c'était la collecte des
informations la collecte des
renseignements ce qu'il lui permettait
d'être au contact des Allemands et
d'ailleurs non seulement des Allemands
de l'Est mais aussi des Allemands de
l'Ouest qui commençaient d'ailleurs à un
tout petit peu s'intéresser à ce marché
par exemple la compagnie de Siemens et
d'autres grandes compagnies ce qui lui a
permis
de peaufiner son allemand d'être en
contact avec ses interlocuteurs qui
appartenaient à un autre monde à un
autre univers intellectuel aussi essayer
de prendre l'ascendant moral
psychologique sur ces intervenants mais
je n'exagérerai jamais le rôle de
Poutine dans cette industrie du crime
que vous évoquez donc c'était plutôt
quelqu'un qui voulait faire des choses
mais qui n'avaient pas énormément
d'importance à cette époque là Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je voudrais vous poser une
question
Bini au brézinski considère que sans
l'Ukraine la Russie ne peut pas être une
puissance impériale est-ce que vous
partagez vous cet avis
historique non je pense pour moi c'est
un peu difficile pour comprendre
pourquoi parce que
parce que les Russie est un grand pays
comme nous avons commencé notre
discussion c'est un vraiment grand
territoire
avec beaucoup de gens avec beaucoup de
ressources naturelles pourquoi il faut
faire une vision pour pour les autres
pays donc les réussites un grand pays
donc pour nous c'est un peu peut-être
une des erreur que nous avons fait comme
comme l'Europe que nous avons pensé que
on peut comprendre les Russie et Poutine
dans notre propre rationalité mais
rationalité des Poutine un peu différent
donc c'est juste justification parfois
pour moi cette explication que le grain
est nécessaire pour les récit de venir
les pays grand pays pour position parce
que pour pour Poutine et pour pour le
régime de Poutine les valeurs sont
différentes comme nous ont discuté un
peu de criminalité un peu de formation
dès que je vais donc c'est le
rationalité totalement de France c'est
les raisons pour lesquelles c'est un peu
difficile maintenant pour expliquer
pourquoi Poutine faire cette invasion
parce que on pense dans notre propre
nationalité mais la nationalité de
Poutine différents ça n'a pas de sens
cette prévision
je l'ai souvent entendu dire ça ils le
disait bien avant je dirais
même avant 90
ce qu'il a voulu dire par là c'est que
je dirais dans la mythologie russe
l'Ukraine c'est tout même c'est qu'hier
c'est le baptême etc c'est à dire c'est
il y avait la volonté de se rattacher à
toute une histoire légendaire c'est ça
le problème et c'est à partir de là
c'est pas c'est pas géopolitiquement
géopolitiquement c'est en effet le pont
vers la vers l'Europe c'est très bien
mais c'était fondamentalement je dirais
dans
dans la pensée dans la vision dans la
conception rue c'est la troisième robe
aussi c'est absolument nécessaire à la
Russie et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il avait pas seulement dit ça il avait
dit dans après 1990 si on veut affaiblir
la Russie c'est en Ukraine qu'il faut
mettre le levier il l'avait dit très
clairement c'est dans le Grand Échiquier
est-ce que je peux dire oui il me semble
quand même que quand briginsky a voulu
parler en fait il a dit que précisément
quand il a parlé de cette ce sujet si la
Russie perdue crâne alors la Russie perd
l'Empire et si elle perd l'Empire la
Russie pourra devenir un État-nation
parce qu'en fait l'un des gros problèmes
auxquels on se heurte aujourd'hui c'est
que la Russie se pense encore comme un
empire en fait nous ne savons même pas
en fait quand vous écoutez par exemple
beaucoup de penseurs russes et vous
diront nous ne savons pas en fait si la
Russie peut devenir un État-nation parce
qu'en fait elle s'est conçue comme une
puissance expansionniste c'est ce que
disait tout à l'heure Alex c'était à la
fois le nid juridique mais c'est aussi
l'expansionnisme la Russie la Moscovie
en fait qui est la véritable le
véritable moment où la Russie se
constitue en tant que en tant que pays
c'est une puissance expansionniste et
donc la question de l'Ukraine c'est
c'est le corps pourquoi est-ce que par
exemple pour Staline engage cette cette
terrible politique de de répression
atroce en Ukraine avec le golodo mort
etc c'est parce que il sait très bien
que c'est le cœur que en fait ils ne
peuvent pas se permettre de laisser une
Ukraine qui déjà en 1917
1918-1920 veut partir et donc ils ne
peuvent pas la laisser partir parce que
à ce moment-là effectivement comme le
dit Madame carradangos il perdent ce qui
est le mythe de la Russie qui est Vienne
et donc il perdent leur disons leur
socle de départ et je pense que c'est
absolument clé c'est un peu comme la
question disons de la Serbie avec la
Yougoslavie à partir du moment où il
perdait ou la Croatie s'en aller la
Serbie
c'était le moment où on pouvait rompre
avec avec l'Empire avec la dimension de
conquête et c'est absolument fondamental
pour la Russie aujourd'hui pour mettre
fin en fait pour mettre un terme à cette
sensation impériale
[Musique]
alors on va rentrer dans le détail sur
le plan militaire avant d'engager
l'invasion de l'Ukraine Poutine et son
armée sont intervenus en Tchétchénie en
Géorgie en Syrie annexer la Crimée et à
chaque fois avec une violence inouïe et
ses interventions militaires ne sont pas
exhaustives cela n'a pas empêché les
grandes capitales européennes et leurs
dirigeants de faire montre pour le moins
de pusillanimité
que pensez-vous finalement de cet
aveuglement politique parce que il a pas
débarqué en Ukraine alors qu'il était un
archange paisible tout ça c'est fait il
y a eu beaucoup de conquêtes militaires
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur non je pense que nous
avons fait de 2 erreurs fondamentales
dans la première
erreur était que nous pensons nous
pensons que peut-être si on a commerçant
avec la Russie on avait invité la guerre
on va faire la dépendance de la Russie
vers l'Europe mais le résultat était
contraire l'Europe devient
dépendance sur la Russie comme comme
avec allemand cette dépendance
énergétique c'est les résultats de cette
liée commerciale ayant économique
est-ce qu'au pays baltes on a cru que
Poutine
allait devenir ce dirigeant démocrate à
la suite de Gorbatchev etc
vous même il y a eu une myopie politique
dans les pays baltes à l'égard de
Poutine parce qu'il a montré sa vraie
face dès le début oui pour nous c'était
très clair que c'est il a beaucoup de
menaces de cette région je pense notre
politique était très cohérente de début
parce que il n'avait aucune invité avec
avec le régime de Poutine peut-être les
dernières fois que notre président a
rencontré Monsieur Poutine c'était 2010
c'était ancien président de Lettonie
griboscate pendant cette réunion et nous
avons reçu les listes de la liste des
choses que on doit faire et je pense
notre réponse c'était nous en fait
totalement tous les choses différentes
comme par construire le terminal GNL
nous avons construit terminal génial et
maintenant nous sommes le premier et le
pays de l'Europe qui nous ont coupé le
gaz et pétrole l'électricité russe parce
que nous avons investi dans notre
indépendance mais je pense que cette
erreur fondamentale était que nous ont
pensé que vraiment si on a discute avec
un peu changé Poutine un peu changer la
Russie mais les résultats étaient
totalement contraires totalement
contraire parce que les Russie a
commencé notre société il s'est Poutine
qui a investi beaucoup sur France
nouvelle sur la Propaganda sur le sur le
deuxième formation sur une
intervention sur les
processus démocratique électoral donc
c'était totalement les résultats
différents
leur Mondeville sans faire un cours de
sciences politiques la France
l'Allemagne l'Italie pendant la dernière
décennie et même avant on dit que
Poutine allait sur le droit chemin même
le président américain Obama en disant
que voilà il fallait arrimer cette
Russie poutinienne aux démocraties parce
que c'était un chemin et pourtant on
s'aperçoit que militairement on va voir
tout à l'heure le volant intérieur il
n'a jamais cessé toutes ces
interventions militaires vous savez
comment vous expliquer ça ben écoutez
moi moi je vous explique par une sorte
de d'auto aveuglement qui a mené un
désastre stratégique pourtant les choses
étaient comme vous l'avez dit claire
depuis le début moi je suis à Moscou au
moment où Vladimir Poutine arrive au
pouvoir en 99 j'ai assisté en fait au
péché original de l'arrivée de Vladimir
Poutine au pouvoir puisqu'il arrive sur
des attentats terroristes au cœur de mon
corps de Moscou qui vont faire exploser
des citoyens russes dont plus personne
ne doute en fait du fait qu'ils ont été
organisés par le Service Secret Service
pour permettre en fait l'arrivée au
pouvoir de Vladimir Poutine et le
déclenchement en fait de la guerre de
conquête de reconquête en Tchétchénie
qui lui a fait un avis de lumière et qui
a lui a permis de passer en fait d'un
pourcentage de trois ou quatre pour cent
de soutien dans la population à une
majorité
[Musique]
vous aviez eu énormément de choses qui
clochaient mes Poutine de lui s'est mis
à nettoyer complètement la scène
politique et ensuite il est parti à
l'extérieur c'est-à-dire il y a une
reconquête intérieure de tous les
leviers de tous les contre-pouvoirs en
Russie du Parlement des médias de
l'oligarchie en 2003 avec avec rhodo
korski qui est jeté en prison et donc
c'est l'effondrement de toute forme de
vrais pouvoir économique et à partir de
là vous avez 2004 où il essaie de
reprendre en main l'Ukraine et en fait
mais l'Occident ferme les yeux pourquoi
il ferme les yeux parce qu'il s'accroche
à l'idée de à l'idée que Poutine quand
même va remettre de l'ordre quand même
oui c'est de l'autoritarisme mais quand
même c'est on peut faire avec lui on
fait du commerce il y en a qui gagnent
de l'argent il y a aussi des gens qui
sont achetés etc etc donc il y a plein
en fait de ressorts qui font que des
gens crient dans le désert et disent que
ça va très mal et que ça va déborder
mais personne ne fait rien et pour eux
venir la question que posée madame
carradoncause sur la question de savoir
pourquoi Vladimir Poutine qui était un
check-list s'est trompé mais en fait
pour une raison très simple c'est parce
qu'en fait il n'y avait plus aucun
garde-fou ni à l'intérieur ni à
l'extérieur l'Occident c'est en couche
devant toutes les dérapages toutes les
dérives l'invasion de la Géorgie
l'annexe vous avez entendu mais c'est
important ce que je voulais dire c'est
que dans la personnalité de Poutine
après le il y a le substrat dont on a
parlé le KGB et le voyou etc mais il y a
aussi l'homme qui appartient dans
certains moments où il livresse de la
puissance
les médias ont aussi leur part parce
qu'ils ont censé Poutine pardon là mais
partout excusez-moi oui mais enfin
écoutez
on a laissé faire mais alors notre
analyse pas tout le monde analyse
Alexandre dans le plan intérieur que sur
le plan extérieur Poutine a montré sa
vraie face
au début et même avant d'arriver au
Kremlin bien sûr mais alors comment le
régime Poutine portait la guerre et
toutes les atrocités que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui comme pour
reprendre l'expression de Jaurès la nuée
portait l'orage pour moi c'était évident
de le début mais pour ça pour savoir ça
pourrait réaliser ça il faut connaître
les Russie et la question que vous posez
pourquoi l'Occident se trompe toujours
sur la Russie c'est une question Émile
éminemment philosophique moi je pense
que le logiciel mental occidental tombe
en panne quand on parle de la Russie de
façon générale on va leur Russie dans la
continuité immuable faisant abstraction
des régimes politiques qui changent
comme si la Russie c'est toujours la
continuité des tsar des soriettes et
après on ne comprend pas très bien mais
enfin bon la le chaos et l'anarchie pour
soviétique etc alors que nous
extrapolons sur la Russie notre propre
rationalité comme si c'était
le discours de la méthode Descartes que
vous essayez de lire dans un asile de
fou c'est-à-dire l'âme slave elle est
tellement compliqué à détecter à déceler
alors que nous les extra pas long ne
propres critères nos propres
frustrations sur la Russie que nous ne
comprenons pas autant de comprenons par
exemple les États-Unis avec
l'anti-amécanisme qui peut garder la
société française autant ne nous
comprenons pas la Russie mais nous
aimons d'une façon générale aussi comme
si elle représentait l'alternative par
rapport à nous donc c'est il y a aussi
un peu dans cette vision française de
façon holistique générale entre je
dirais de façon un peu peut-être
grossière entre Tchaïkovsky de stoïevski
et vodka donc il faut à un moment donné
passer à une vraie vision de la Russie
qui tient compte du changement d'origine
dans ce Bible le régime d'État il faut
pas pour confondre avec le régime de
Soviets le régime de yilside il faut pas
confondre avec le régime de Poutine donc
pourquoi nous ne pouvons déceler tous
les régimes politiques dans d'autres
pays du monde alors que je répète notre
logiciel mental tombant pas quand il
s'agit de la Russie alors madame Carrère
d'Encausse justement je vais faire une
comparaison historique qui n'est pas
tout à fait exact mais pour comprendre
les choses si on prend l'événement et
l'avènement du nazisme on voit comment
Hitler conquère le conquère le pouvoir
la nuit de Cristal il y a les mesures en
18 il y avait la restocratie qui qui
adhère puis la Wehrmacht etc quand on
prend l'histoire de Poutine même si les
choses ne sont pas similaires on
s'aperçoit que sur le flanc le plan
militaire comme sur le plan intérieur
lentement de 1000 en a parlé il a mis à
bas la justice il a mis à bas les
libertés de Gorbatchev il a mis en bas
les oligares qui étaient pour une
ouverture vers l'Occident il s'est
attaqué à tous ses voisins il a
considéré que le prochain c'était lui
c'était chez lui etc comment vous
expliquer que malgré tout
l'Europe même les États-Unis et tout
sont là dans un attentisme et en
espérant quoi attendez je crois qu'il
faut pas bousculer le calendrier quand
Poutine arrive c'est la fin de l'année
1999 à l'issue de dix années de chaos en
Russie de chaos qui sont qui étaient
inéluctables en effet démantèlement du
système soviétique d'un système comme ça
après 75 ans c'était une affaire
extraordinairement compliquée et moi je
me souviens de Jeffrey's big piquant à
moi le charmant jeune homme de Chicago
ou bien c'était intéressant comme
expérience il s'est trompé aussi oui
depuis le thé ce genre de ce que je veux
dire ça montre là aussi l'aveuglement
l'idée que c'était une expérience qu'on
faisait l'expérience a été désastreuse
ça aide parce que c'était très compliqué
ça a ajouté au cas où l'Occident a vu
déjà avec une certaine terreur ce chaos
parce que n'oubliez pas les États-Unis
c'est ailleurs mais la Russie c'est en
Europe c'est tout même sur notre
continent c'est notre c'est un pays avec
lequel on voisine et on peut faire ce
qu'on veut on peut pas le prendre pour
aller le mettre de l'autre côté en Asie
c'est et il y a déjà eu cette espèce de
désarroi devant les années yelsin en
plus nous avons eu des critères simples
on s'est dit il y a un ivrogne qui est
là qui fait n'importe quoi qui introduit
un désordre formidable il y a des
espèces de type qui ont fait fort c'est
pas très bien ce qui se passe et on a vu
avec un certain soulagement un type qui
sortait on ne sait pas d'où parce que
personne ne le connaissait il faut pas
oublier qu'il y a une succession de
Premier ministre quel signe a essayé les
uns après les autres avec l'idée que
l'un de ceux-là se succéder bon et puis
ça marchait plus il était très malade et
il s'est rattrapé avec ce dernier qui
était Poutine déjà si vous voulez il y a
eu un soulagement on s'est dit ben voilà
un peu d'ordre qui revient dans ce pays
et Poutine a su tout de même au début se
poser en champions de Lord ça c'est une
première chose la seconde chose moi je
voudrais insister c'est tout de même je
ne pense pas que ce soit un gyné
politique mais je pense qu'il a été à
droite pendant une période de sa vie et
notamment quand il voulait faire une
opération extérieure il s'arrangeait
pour que pour pouvoir la justice pour
avoir une raison de se précipiter la
première grande opération extérieure qui
fait je parle pas de la Tchétchénie la
Tchétchénie c'est une affaire interne ça
fait très peur et n'oubliez pas la
Tchétchénie toute cette affaire là il y
a eu 2001 les attentats terroristes aux
États-Unis etc déjà le l'islam devient
quelque chose d'un peu inquiétant pour
les Européens on se rend compte qu'il y
a tout de même un problème qui se pose à
nous bon donc il réglait des on s'est
dit il règle ses problèmes là-bas mais
quand il est allé en Géorgie en
il est pas allé comme en Ukraine il a
attendu l'occasion sa cachemilie la lui
a donné il lui a donné un prétexte il y
est allé et évidemment on a dit bon
quand il est quand il s'est emparé de la
Crimée en 2014 c'est pareil il a sauté
sur un prétexte sur la les dispositions
linguistiques de l'Ukraine et du même
coup tout le monde personne n'a bougé là
ce qui est très intéressant maintenant
il y va sans prendre de précaution et
c'est un changement je dirais de
comportement qui est intéressant et qui
explique que tout d'un coup on a dit
c'est curieux pourquoi est-ce qu'il est
allé là mais il y avait pas de raison ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que il y a
un comportement chez lui qui évolue une
espèce de prudence qui a évolué
progressivement la Syrie ne l'oubliez
pas tout de même le problème du
terrorisme daesh nous terrorisons il a
joué là-dessus il a joué tout de même
sur le fait que le l'Occident se battait
contre le terrorisme islamiste et
qu'après tout en soutenant Bachar il
soutenait le type qu'ils prétendaient
cassé ça
je pense qu'on ne fait pas assez
attention à cette je ne suis pas que
c'est une évolution de la personnalité
je n'en sais rien justement ça fait
partie des questions que je me pose
je voudrais avoir votre avis est-ce que
dans les Pays-Bas on considère
que le Kremlin aujourd'hui c'est une
mafia criminelle
tous les trucs étaient faits par cette
régime mais c'est notre pas de l'amour
qui a fait la déclaration publique
une balance sur la Russie comme sur le
régime de protéines comme régime
criminel terroriste etc donc ça ça fait
pas notre politicien mais je pense
c'était vraiment nos erreurs de Georgie
et de Crimée qui était de basse pour
encourager Poutine pour continuer parce
que qu'est-ce que c'est possible le jour
J c'est rien nous on est revenu sur
business rapidement sans aucune
conséquence pour Poutine qu'est-ce que
c'est possible après le premier en
composition du Crémieu dans une base
c'était les sanctions théoriques on ne
peut pas quelque chose qui sont très
important pour Poutine et pour lui
c'était les messages très clair que il
peut continuer il n'y a aucune
résistance ce n'est aucune é
de très important de notre côté de
d'oxydants et ça encourager pour une
pour continuer mais est-ce que vous par
exemple la Lituanie vous avez armé
réarmé parce que vous craignez une
intervention militaire oui je pense
après
le don de basse c'était grandement dans
notre politique ainsi que contient le
financement de l'armée maintenant c'est
plus que 2,5% de notre pays dédié pour
pour la défense et nous allons changer
ça rapidement investir pour avoir aussi
la présence de l'OTAN avec la mission de
le temps
chez nous dans notre région donc nous
ont investi beaucoup aussi sur les
cybersécurités sur sur les résilience de
notre société est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet aujourd'hui une source c'est
tout le monde pensait que
Poutine peut intervenir dans les pays
baltes
si il va gagner bien sûr il va parce que
pour lui ça sera on a encore un message
qu'il peut continuer il n'a rien il a
personne qui peut arrêter lui dire oui
en fait pour finalement aller à la fois
dans le sens de ce que dit et incarne en
cause et Monsieur l'Ambassadeur c'est
que effectivement il s'est end Hardy
c'est à dire que le l'ADN et là sont
sont sa vision du monde son mode de
comportement son mépris à la fois de la
loi de l'homme des des autres pays sa
logique de puissance de contrôle de
soumission elle existe dès le départ en
fait comme ça qu'il a été formaté mais
c'est un homme qui au départ est assez
timide qui qui regarde comment
l'Occident se comporte il faut pas
oublier que justement c'est un homme qui
sort un peu de nulle part qui n'est pas
qui n'a jamais eu le qui n'a pas fait de
son chemin par exemple dans la politique
publique donc quand il se retrouve au
Kremlin au départ il c'est prudent avec
les occidentaux il veut il veut il est
flatté il veut être reçu au G7 au G8 et
d'ailleurs contrairement à ce qu'on ce
qu'on racontait tous ceux qui disaient
qu'on était pas assez sympa avec lui et
que c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient énervé
il a été au contraire reçu par tout
embrassé par l'Occident et donc ce qui
se passait c'est que il a peu il a peu à
peu près conscience que les occidentaux
étaient plus ilanimes pour reprendre
l'adjectif que vous utilisez qu'ils
étaient lâches qu'ils étaient faibles et
en fait c'est cette c'est cette
politique d'affe de d'apaisement cette
politique de faiblesse en fait qui a
créé le Poutine que l'on a aujourd'hui
c'est à dire un Poutine comme je le
disais tout à l'heure qui confonctionne
sans garde-fou
avoir une précision une ivresse si vous
voulez il y a une ivresse aujourd'hui du
pouvoir c'est un c'est une autocratie
dans une sorte de psychose aiguë vous
l'avez dit
qui a une pointe que je voudrais
préciser avec vous vous avez été
vous connaissez la Russie vous êtes
russe est-ce qu'à votre avis va vous
étiez mon nom Meli que complètement
ukrainien bon vous êtes bon donc la
question que je voudrais vous poser à
votre avis en tant qu' ancien diplomate
si vous remettez cette casquette
on dit qu'au début il était timide il a
voulu tromper les Occidentaux etc est-ce
que vous pensez pas qu'on regarde ce
qu'il a fait sur le plan extérieur comme
sur le plan intérieur il avait la
stratégie d'un dictateur dès le départ
je dirais pas la stratégie de diététrie
que son logiciel mental n'a pas changé
son logiciel mental de quelqu'un qui
n'est qui était un voyou de
Saint-Pétersbourg en étant président de
la Russie c'est quand même un formidable
trajet donc est-ce qu'il est venu avec
une stratégie de pouvoir du tout il n'a
pas d'aide d'origine il n'a pas de
stratégie c'est une c'est quelqu'un qui
se révèle au gré des événements qui
changent ça c'est vrai il y a une
certaine capacité sans doute
d'adaptation mais je dirais que son
logiciel mental fondamentalement c'est
celui d'un bébé d'un enfant de la guerre
froide donc la guerre froide c'était la
bipolarité du monde il y a l'Union
soviétique d'un côté et les États-Unis
de l'autre il y a le communisme et le
capitalisme et l'horloge mentale de
Poutine est resté coincé pendant cette
période là donc là dessus il n'a pas
évolué du tout donc c'est-à-dire lui il
a profité justement de cette situation
qui est changé de ces années 90 que nous
avons déjà évoqué le chaos et le
ressenti de l'humiliation humiliation du
peuple russe je dis bien ressenti parce
que pour moi c'était pas une véritable
humiliation et il s'est positionné comme
réparateur de cette humiliation
nationale un peu à la démarche de
quelqu'un à notre personnage historique
dont le nom peut-être je ne prononcerai
pas qui est aussi se nourrit de
l'humiliation après le traité de
Versailles voilà donc c'est pour que
c'était sa démarche de quelqu'un qui
répare l'humiliation et aussi et je
termine là-dessus pourquoi son logiciel
mental d'un enfant de la guerre froide
n'a pas changé parce que comme disait
l'heure il s'enfiltre dans les
interstices de la faiblesse des
faiblesses occidentales c'est à dire dès
qu'il y a une possibilité de frapper il
frappe tout simplement parce que nous on
est souvent myope je reprends notre
expression nous on est souvent lâche
c'est-à-dire nous on est toujours en
retard alors que lui il anticipe
toujours et comme disait leur aussi il
n'a pas de garde de fou il n'a pas de
limite alors que nous nous en avons
beaucoup nous nous sommes imposés les
lignes rouges nous avons la loi que nous
respectons alors que lui il n'a rien à
respecter c'est quelqu'un qui se
déchaîne finalement dans les
réalisations de ces fantasmes et de sa
vision du monde merci Alexandre
[Musique]
on va essayer d'aborder l'avenir parce
que l'avenir c'est quand même
un jour la fin de cette guerre
comment vous l'imaginez
une Carrère d'Encausse vercale évolution
est-ce que ce seront des hommes comme
cadirofigogine pas touchée enfin tout va
pas trop cher tous ces gens qui
l'entourent les silos VIKids les
services secrets etc est-ce que c'est
eux qui vont prendre la suite ou est-ce
que vous voyez quelque chose de plus
apaisé au regard du chaos actuel je
préfère laisser les autres parler parce
que pour le coup je n'imagine pas pour
l'instant
plutôt pessimiste ou optimiste ni l'un
ni l'autre je n'arrive pas à imaginer je
pense que tout est possible
qu'on peut avoir sauf je dirais une
révolution en Russie du type 1917 ça je
crois pas qu'on est ça mais
que quelque chose se produise au niveau
du pouvoir et que ça ça me paraît
plausible à un moment donné mais qui
peut le faire je ne sais pas encore donc
je préfère
puisque la guerre finira bien un jour
même si elle dure encore un certain
temps à court terme
c'est la défaite militaire du régime de
Poutine qui s'impose c'est-à-dire le
crâne doit gagner cette guerre ça c'est
pas une prévision écrasante et avec
l'aide et soutient occidentaux beaucoup
plus massif et éradical je dirais que
celui qui existe aujourd'hui parce que
finalement le craindre se bat pour sa
liberté pour sa démocratie mais elle se
bat aussi pour notre démocratie si on
laisse Poutine gagner cette guerre c'est
l'Occident en tant que civilisation qui
pourrait sortir de l'histoire donc ça
c'est le premier point donc là la chute
du régime de Poutine pour moi ça ne veut
pas dire la chute de la Russie ça veut
dire aussi
est-ce que vous seriez favorable à ce
que les responsables et au premier chef
Vladimir Poutine soit jujué par un
tribunal international et est-ce que ce
serait la condition pour l'émergence
d'une Russie nouvelle madame Carrère
d'encauste parce que là c'est une vraie
question non je ne réponds pas je laisse
mais sur le sur cette question je ne
répond pas là-dessus parce que sur
l'avenir je ne m'engage pas moi c'est
pas sur l'avenir mais est-ce que vous
pensez
qu'il est nécessaire de nettoyer les
écuries d'objet c'est au russe de le
faire oui de le faire et je pense que
c'est de réussite ça doit partir moi
c'est ma conviction c'est qu'il faut
qu'il se passe quelque chose c'est à
dire qu'il y a un tribunal en Russie qui
juge les crimes de guerre pour commencer
il faut que je dirais qu'il se passe et
je pense que ça repose sur la défaite
militaire de Poutine
son entourage je ne sais qui se
débarrasse de Poutine c'est la première
chose après alors après l'hormoneville
vous pensez que un tribunal jugeant ces
crimes de guerre c'est la condition pour
une Russie plus pacifiée moi je pense
qu'il va falloir que si on veut en fait
kemerge une Russie
démocratique ce que tout le monde
souhaite mais qui mais qui à mon avis
est un pari énorme c'est à dire il faut
bien je pense qu'il faut quand même
avant de vous répondre dire que
aujourd'hui la Russie est dans un abîme
ce qu'il faut effectivement si on veut
sortir de cette abîme et on veut aussi
que l'Europe devienne enfin un pays qui
soit délivré en fait de du deuxième de
totalitarisme du 20e siècle qui a
continué donc il faudra il faudra un
procès du communisme du putinisme et une
et effectivement une détente
y compris évidemment les États-Unis
c'est la condition sinequanone de la
sortie de cette situation
ubues qui tragique dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons aujourd'hui et aussi c'est
la base d'une nouvelle Russie Russie
démocratique connectée avec le monde
avec la globalisation du 21e siècle
on a plus de temps vous voulez dire un
mot je vous laisse le Mondeville
là-dessus mais on n'a pas beaucoup de
temps que la grande la grande question
c'est quels seront les modalités de ce
de ce procès dont dont parlons de cette
justice que nous nous voulons tous car
elle nous paraît indispensable est-ce
que ce sera avec un régime qui émergera
qui sera justement si ça s'effondre s'il
perd la guerre le régime s'effondrera il
y aura une volonté russe de faire ce
procès ou est-ce que ce sera quelque
chose qui se passera à l'extérieur et
donc là c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
voir comment ça pourra fonctionner ça
tout ça c'est des questions énormes
parce que quand il y a
pardonne-moi l'occupation de l'Allemagne
c'est ça que je veux dire alors là on va
buter sur quelque chose de très
compliqué en fait à organiser si parce
que la guerre n'a pas lieu sur le
territoire de la Russie mais sur le
territoire
d'encaus je pense que c'est au russe de
régler le problème c'est à eux de faire
justice de ce qui se passe absolument
parce que je pense que pour qu'ils
acceptent c'est à eux de le faire et
alors je voudrais juste dire un mot la
Russie ne se porte pas bien en ce moment
mais tout d'abord regardez la fuite des
cerveaux et la fuite véritablement de
population qui s'est produit dans ce
pays elle est beaucoup plus importante
que celle qui s'est produite après 1917
c'est-à-dire que véritablement il y a un
sursaut de la partie la plus dynamique
la plus vivante la plus intellectuelle
du pays ça a une signification
considérable merci
Madame merci mesdames merci messieurs
d'avoir participé à cette émission alors
une brève bibliographie
alors l'hormoneville a rappelé ce grand
ouvrage de Catherine Belton les hommes
de Poutine alors apprend tout sur le KGB
et sur les liens criminels du KGB dans
lesquels a plongé
Vladimir Poutine je voudrais signaler de
Madame Carrère d'Encausse aux éditions
pluriels Alexandra koh-lantaï la
Valkyrie de la Révolution personnage
extrêmement intéressant
vous avez l'air d'être très attaché à
cette personne c'est un personnage très
séduisant c'est un modèle je dirais pour
notre époque d'une certaine façon ou
alors c'est une féministe comme on en
trouve peu et c'est elle que vous qui a
inventé cette notion de finalisation
absolument peut-être qui a réussi à
sauver la Finlande véritablement assouvi
par la neutralité l'indépendance de la
Finlande alors qu'elle était ambassadeur
et à ce moment-là je dirais le concept a
servi après bah très bien alors quand
l'Ukraine se lève
constante ainsi golf et leur Mondeville
en un mot d'après vous la naissance de
la Nation ukrainienne elle est liée à ce
coup bas
poutinien ou ça existait avant ça
existait avant c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui c'est le moment où le
miracle devient manifeste de le miracle
de la résistance mais en réalité la
nation ukrainienne est en marge depuis
très longtemps et nous nous n'avions pas
mis sur notre carte mentale et c'est ce
que ce livre et c'est de raconter en
fait alors je voudrais rappeler
également de l'hormoneville chez Grasset
la reconquête russe des 2008 mais ça
raconte ça a annoncé exactement ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en tout cas une
drôle de reconquête je voudrais rappeler
de Alexandre meldik le monde nous
appartient alors c'est de quel monde
vous faites allusion le monde global
interconnecté en interdépendance
c'est-à-dire celui que j'enseigne un
géopolitique le monde du XXIe siècle et
la base de chaque individu de notre
planète quelle que soit sa couleur de
peau la géolocalisation dans ce monde
merci alors avant de vous quitter je
voudrais vous laisser avec cette pensée
de Philippe rot qui vient en écho de la
fin de notre émission les procès des
criminels de guerre
laver la terre de ses démons une fois
pour toute
[Musique]